[Music]
what's going on everybody Ian Harding
here on behalf of PFF welcome to BR
Fantasy Live we got some snow we got
some fantasy freaking football to talk
about here playoffs on the way lots of
goodness coming up but first I want to
talk to you guys about some of the big
injuries happening and always eventful
Thursday afternoon in the NFL we do have
t Higgins popping up on the injury
report with a midweek hamstring injury
never good to see that getting the
limited session in could mean bigger
roles than usual for Jamar Chase and
Tyler Boyd if he's ultimately sidelined
also have saquon Barkley popping up with
a neck injury on Thursday hey Matt
burrito guys if he is out there in those
fantasy leagues and you have an extra
bench spot not the worst guy to go out
there and pick up I'm not saying he
would go out there and be a Tony Paul or
Alex Alexander Madison you know top tier
handcuffed that sets there would be
someone especially in a week with six
buys that would be pretty tough to keep
out of the top 20 or so running backs
also keep an eye on what's going on and
the Cardinals wide receiver room Rondell
Moore still dealing with this groin
injury and did not manage to practice to
start the week despite having a bye week
to get right they did not play until
Monday night against the Patriots so
rondelle with the groin and DeAndre
Hopkins with an illness need to be
monitored throughout the weekend also
have treyland Brooks back to back dmps
due to that concussion not looking too
good for Sunday so without Brooks in the
picture don't exactly trust any of these
wide receivers but guys we do have chig
ogonquo um tough name to say apologies
for that one but the tight end man small
sample size be damned this dude actually
ranks first in yards per reception first
in yards per out run among 37 qualified
tight ends this year so coming off a
season high and snaps and targets five
straight cans with at least 30 receiving
yards you guys have seen that tight end
landscape you can do worse sometimes
than at least having an explosive player
and that certainly is what chick has
been to this point in the season
Leonard fournette do addition to the
injury report exactly about shop white
fantasy managers want to see especially
after we saw just how split that usage
was last week so with fournette and
honestly what Rashad White gonna be
another situation worth monitoring this
Sunday because if both those guys are
healthy all of a sudden we don't feel
the same need to force them both into
the fantasy lineup and also Deontay
Johnson popping up with a downgrade dnp
on Thursday with a hip injury I know
it's Kenny Pickett it's George Pickens
it's an offense that we haven't seen
have any sort of consistency this season
that said guys if we do take deante
Johnson out of the picture one of the
most targeted wide receivers in the NFL
105 without a touchdown this year could
mean good things for Pickens and the
rest of the game so with that everyone
again welcome to be our Fantasy Live
presented by State Farm I'm Ian Hardison
this is our last show of the season so
appreciate you Grinders that have been
out there with us again we got some
Fantasy Playoff spots to clinch if we
haven't gotten there already and why not
do so from the friendly confines of us
snowy Cincinnati so appreciate all you
appreciate State Farm and we have a
great show for you today want to go
through eight players whose stockings
are looking up messing in with the
Christmas theme you guys see how it is
stock is going up here ahead of the
fantasy playoffs so I am going to talk
mostly about guys I'm hopeful or either
on your waiver wire or on your bench and
are going to be a little bit tougher
Starship decisions as easy and as fun as
it would be to tell you guys to you know
play Tony Pollard play Devante Adams
trying to go on a limb just a little bit
here so with that guys let's get going
with quarterback and as I say that I'm
cheating a little bit on the first one
but Joe burrow guys stock just continues
to Fly Sky High and I just want to
reinforce how good he has actually been
this season in terms of his ability just
rack up these astronomical Fantasy Point
totals I know we usually look at the you
know Mahomes Lamar Jacksons kylo
Murray's Jalen Hurst Josh Allens of the
world as a tear gap between them and
then more so the pocket pastors like
burrow but low keeping running the ball
very well this season in his own right
and you look up guys burrow actually has
had now let's see six finishes as a top
two fantasy quarterback in his last 14
games so burrow is actually given you
the weak winning performances that you
maybe didn't even necessarily expect
when you drafted him back in what round
seven or round eight in August so on the
season very much getting himself back
into that mvp discussion number three
among 38 quarterbacks in PFF passed in
grade fifth and pass are rating seventh
in yards per attempt Sixth and adjust
the completion rate pick your favorite
passing stat and there's a good chance
Bartow is going to be a top tier
quarterback in it he gets the Buccaneers
the Patriots and the bills down the
stretch so not exactly layups but with a
healthy Jamar Chase hopefully with t
Higgins not having this hamstring issue
for too long Joe burrow could have even
more goodness on the way when it matters
most in Fantasyland
now one that's a little bit uh you know
not exactly such a sure start every
every week person like Joe burrow we do
have Jared Goff coming off another game
where we saw that when everyone is
healthy in Detroit derekoff and everyone
involved are capable of putting up some
legit numbers we've actually seen this
now for multiple four week stretches
during the first four weeks of the
season the Lions actually ranked as the
number one ranked score on offense in
the entire NFL Now Monroe Saint Brown
DeAndre Swift got hurt Hawkinson got
traded things went South in a hurry and
over their next four games they actually
ranked 31st only the Steelers were
scoring at a lower rate than the Detroit
Lions but guess what DJ shark back
Jameson Williams a healthy sun god
DeAndre swept back in Action over these
past four weeks now we have seen the
Lions return to be in the second ranked
scoring offense in the NFL behind only
the Dallas Cowboys so with golf man this
upcoming schedule looking great we get
the Vikings this week highest game total
excuse me tied for the highest game
total of the week at 52 and a half a
little bit of a tough match match up on
week 15 against the Jets but winnable
enough spot against the Panthers in week
16 and honestly guys if you can't keep
golf on that roster please do so just
for week 17 alone at home against the
Chicago Bears defense that has just been
abysmal ever since they really decided
to you know trade away all their good
players at the trade deadline now we're
helping them I should say not helping
them complete that tank job Jared Goff
down the rest of the way don't be
surprised if he's a more consistent top
10 fantasy quarterback than you were
expecting when the season started
appreciate everyone out there in the
chat gonna have a ton of time for Star
sick questions here after we get through
the rest of the positions but certainly
got a few right now from my guy Mason
Gore Gino or Justin Herbert it's
hilarious that this is actually a
reasonable question but I am still going
to give it to Justin Herbert you know
pop probably getting Mike Williams back
this week we just haven't seen hardly
many games I mean what like a half a
couple quarters in week one of Herbert
having each of Keenan and Mike Williams
Gerald ever and Austin Eckler healthy
when he does have those guys cemented as
a top five quarterback with all due
respect to arguably the comeback Player
of the Year and Geno Smith from Max Q
Acres or Isaiah Pacheco definitely
Isaiah Pacheco Man four straight weeks
now with over 15 touches I mean that's
like a hopeful total for cam makers and
you look at last week yes he did find
the end zone twice still dead last
though in the entire NFL in yards for
Kerry not exactly you know the best stat
to be at the complete bottom of so with
Isaiah Pacheco look we're getting 15
touches in the number one ranked scoring
offense in the NFL you can do a lot
worse from te BR start two Brita Hubbard
you know Benjamin dontrow Hilliard yeah
man I appreciate the kind words they're
on the thank you so starting to man The
bye weeks are hitting you hard I can
tell on that one it's probably going to
be Matt it's gonna be Chupa Hubbard and
Don Trail Hilliard I would say out of
that group we have no expectations for
you know Benjamin right now I wonder if
you're playing a little bit of a prank
on me here because this is a pretty
terrible group of four there but jokes
on you because I do think chuba and Don
Cho heard are the Best Bets from that
group but let's talk a little more about
these running backs and one guy that I
brought up last week that hey actually
has been now making even bigger moves
and could be in play down the stretch as
a weekly starter New York Jets rookie
running back zone of the night where's
my Santa hoes at he's been going wild
this whole time
there he is appreciate you Santa but
with Donovan now we got a little bit of
good news from actual head coach of New
York Jets and Robert Sala because
Michael Carter is expected to come back
this week but Salah already straight up
said that Donovan is quote unquote not
going anywhere so look it's an NFL coach
we know that we're not going to get you
know their complete death chart and
their usage laid out for us each and
every week so I recognize that this is a
little bit coach speaky but why would he
be going really too far I mean the guy
always done over the past two weeks 221
yards on 37 total touches while boasting
pff's second highest elusive rating the
guys look good out there and with the
Jets searching for an identity in the
Run game ever since losing Breeze Hall
it sure looks like bam AKA is on of the
night is that guy for now so we've
talked a lot about you know trying to
get ourselves in the right position to
have these great schedules going into
the fantasy playoffs and you look at it
now guys weeks 15 through 17 the Lions
the Jaguars and the Seahawks for zone of
the night so I still think it's going to
be a bit of an annoying situation we
have Donovan there Michael Carter and Ty
Johnson this week's matchup against the
bills not one I want to overly mess with
but another solid week another week of
seeing Donovan again in a position to
get 15 to 20 touches per game we're
going to be loving him sooner rather
than later make sure if he's not on your
bench already and he has a chance and
you have a chance to add him go get zone
of the night
I also want to talk about another guy in
a similar role we just had a start to
question with him but Chiefs rookie
running back Isaiah Pacheco love seeing
all these rookies starting to get going
right around holidays so with Pacheco
again I mentioned this before but four
straight games with at least 14 carries
and he's managed to find the end zone
and two of those four games so that's
really been the only problem in Kansas
City I mean you watch these Chiefs games
and I don't know what happens to like
Andy Reid and obviously the play calling
structure once they get inside the
10-yard line it's just one underhand
shovel after another tight end or Travis
Kelsey is going to take all of them they
hate running the ball inside the fight
yard line one of only five NFL offenses
to actually throw the ball on at least
65 percent of their snaps inside the 10.
so that hasn't been great for Pacheco
but guess what when you're in the NFL's
number one scoring offense you're going
to get a lot of chances even if you got
Patrick Mahomes throwing the ball to his
Hearts Delight inside the tent so this
week isn't the best on paper the Broncos
have a great defense and everything and
that's in the pass in the run but still
the chief status is nine point favorites
you would like to think that their lead
back is going to be able to overcome
that and similar to Donovan Knight
though he is as iffy as this week might
be guys stock is only soaring higher
once we get to the fantasy playoffs in
weeks 15 through 17 Chiefs running backs
have the easiest schedule excuse me
second easiest schedule of anyone out
there for their running back so the
Houston Texans the Seattle Seahawks in
another spot against the Broncos don't
be surprised if we see Isaiah Pacheco
winning some fantasy championships here
down the stretch
appreciate your chat Alex Caruso Donovan
at night or Damien Pierce Donovan Knight
man but that's okay I am gonna actually
lean towards Donovan here it's very
close but my God man like just with
Damien Pierce you could not pick a worse
spot for him here 17 point underdogs on
the road against the Cowboys give me
Donovan uh from Miller Lite uh Rondell
Moore Michael Gallup or Donovan people's
Jones I'm giving the slight Edge to Don
for people's Jones here as much as that
as that game script I just mentioned is
bad for Damien Pierce because the Texans
are probably going to need to pass and
we're going to see too much Dario gumbo
Wale and Rex Burkhead once you know the
game if and when I should say the game
gets out of hand on the other side of
things I don't think the Cowboys gonna
have to keep their foot on the gas all
that long in the passing game so with
Donovan people's Jones it was a really
rough first game for Deshaun Watson out
there but I think it would make sense if
he gets back to looking more so like the
top 10 real life quarterback he was from
2017 to 2020 so with dpj really does
profile a bit as Watson's new were
Fuller of sorts and my God where is Will
Fuller that's a good question there but
give me Donovan people's Jones in that
one moving right along to the wide
receivers so
you guys have been listening to me all
year I'm not huge on the victory Labs
but we did bring up a couple weeks ago
DJ Moore as someone that could help you
down to stretch and it is looking good
for the Panthers oh
ho ho ho ho wide receiver one so with DJ
Moore here Sam darnold this is so sad to
say out loud guys but Sam darnold
relatively for DJ Moore is a big time
quarterback upgrade for the man I mean
just DJ Moore Terry mcclorn one of them
is going to be if not they already are
this generation's Alan Robinson before
him Andre Johnson you know the Great
Wide Receiver at least have to play with
one terrible quarterback after another
in the NFL so with DJ Moore second best
schedule for wide receivers here in
weeks 15 through 17 against the Steelers
the Lions and the Buccaneers and when
you just look at what he's been able to
do with Sam darnold I mean last year in
a 12-game sample size guys he had 9.8
targets per game average 70 receiving
yards and 5.7 catches this year before
getting Sam back only 7.5 targets and 46
receiving yards so but DJ Moore in the
past it was like we had a pretty
consistent wide receiver three wide
receiver two but we just wanted more we
wanted that wide receiver one production
that we know he's talented enough to get
this year it was like a wide receiver
for a wide receiver five and we were
just praying to have someone that we
could even think about taking off the
fancy bench at this point we do have
that in DJ more so again it's been
inconsistent hasn't been a good year but
I do think the best could still be to
come here for DJ Moore fresh off a bye
week or the week before that guys 100
plus yards and a touchdown with a lot of
that coming right in stud Broncos
cornerback Patrick certan's Grill
also want to give a shout out to a guy
that's a little bit banged up this week
but I think once he gets right could
really help us there in weeks 15 through
17. Houston Texans second year wide
receiver Nico Collins
ho ho ho
with Nico guys he is not expected to
play this week so that could be a reason
why he's actually available on your
waiver wire in the first place if
someone just needs to go ahead and get a
starter in there so dealing with the
foot injury that said Brandon Cooks is
dealing with the cap injury that already
kept him out last week as well and in
Cook's case it is something where I
wonder if just in the middle of this
last season they do decide enough is
enough and they basically shut them down
down the stretch so that would lead Nico
Collins to be in a position where he
just keeps on keeping on getting a bunch
of targets over these last four weeks 10
7 9 and 10 targets and accordingly he's
been able to post wide receiver 20 41 43
in wide receiver 30 finishes so I get it
not exactly World beating numbers there
but Beggars can't be choosers on the
waiver wire in Weak freaking 14 of the
season so third best schedule in weeks
15 to 17 among wide receivers we got the
Chiefs the Titans and the Jaguars
rounding things out so Nico Collins like
DJ Moore a solid wide receiver three
that I think does have the goodness
matchups to Boom in the right time down
the stretch
appreciate your chat Mario Joseph Watson
or Huntley I am still going back the
well with the Sean Watson Tyler Huntley
again very good streamer ad I do have
him as a top 15 option out to position
but I do think burrow versus Watson
probably going to be seeing you know a
rare and AFC North shootout this week
from JAG Acres or Jeff Wilson Jr oh I am
so sorry you're in that position man
looking at my ranks right now Eileen
just barely to Jeff Wilson you know
every time every week when I make my
rankings I usually have a player where
if I really don't want to play that guy
he ends up being like my benchmarked and
deciding like okay who to put behind him
and Jeff Wilson is that guy this week so
the fact Acres couldn't bust that past
them not good at ours also with the
Acres guys they did bring up Malcolm
Brown to the act of roster and again the
only consistency in this Los Angeles
Rams backfield the entire season has
been the general inconsistency for
everyone involved so with Acres like
yeah if they find a way to get up by
multiple touchdowns which seems
incredibly unlikely then maybe he can
lock his way into the end zone once or
twice and get 15 carries but they're not
going to be efficient and I just don't
trust that John Walford or Baker
Mayfield LED offense to give him those
opportunities all right guys two tight
ends to talk about before we really get
going into a lot of your start sick
questions as always appreciate all of
you tuning in to be our Fantasy Live
let's talk a little about New England
Patriots tight end Hunter Henry already
had a nice nice Thanksgiving four big
weeks could be on the White
with Henry there's two main factors that
go into liking his fantasy potential
here down the stretch the first one is
the absence of Patriots number one pass
game option Jacoby Myers if you guys
remember last Thursday night took that
really hard hit uh In The End Zone had a
touchdown in his hands then basically
got knocked out by the Bill's safety who
was immediately ejected so hope to Kobe
gets better wasn't able to practice on
Thursday though which is not put him on
the right track for Monday night when
Hunter Henry gets to face the Cardinals
League worst defense and fantasy points
per game allowed the tight ends and this
isn't one of those things where it's
just Travis Kelsey and Mark Andrews
balled out against them they shut down
everyone else I mean Noah fan went for
96 yards and then six guesses for 45
yards against these guys Dallas Goddard
had 95 yards Kittle found the end zone
twice DeJuan Johnson found the end zone
twice against the Cardinals this has
been really for several years now the
League's single worst defense defending
tight ends so we have Henry with the
great matchup coming off a week where he
already had a 79 route rate that that's
all we can ask for at the tight end
position and potentially getting more
tasking volume than ever without Jacoby
Myers I love Hunter Henry this week and
Beyond we're talking about the third
best schedule for tight ends in weeks 15
through 17. get in the face the Raiders
the Bengals and the Dolphins down the
stretch and finally guys again what a
year for tight ends if you don't have
Travis Kelsey you've probably been
looking at the waiver wire at least one
week or another which takes us to Denver
Broncos rookie tight end Greg dulches
wait till you guys see the mustache on
our Santa
oh there he is I love that guy I'm just
just everything about great daughters if
he doesn't have a you know a head and
shoulders uh sponsorship deal by this
off season he should fire his manager
but with Dolce guys similar to Hunter
Henry where okay we've already seen him
be able to give us at least decent
fantasy production I mean PPR tied at 11
tight end seven tight end nine most
recently tight end two finishes really
this season so he's had some Duds there
because who hasn't has some Duds and the
Denver Broncos offense but we can be a
little bit more confident about doltres
down the stretch like Hunter Henry
because the number one pass game option
in this offense just got injured and I
ain't talking about Carl and Sutton
dealing with that hamstring injury so
unlikely to play this week and hey I
already said Hunter Henry's second best
schedule of the position we have the
ninth best for dolches down the stretch
so gets the Cardinals in week 15 which
again League worst defense before
reasonable enough matchups against the
Rams and the Chiefs in week 16 and 17.
so we had Nathaniel Hackett even say
this week that Dolce is basically
playing more of a wide receiver role but
what's really good about what he's doing
guys he's still spending 52 percent of
his snaps in line we talk about guys
like Kyle Pitts playing a bunch in the
slot or out Wyatt and Mike toseki and
that's fine and dandy but they're
usually getting matched up more against
quarterbacks when they do that I think
Dolce should continue to be able to
Feast against linebackers and safeties
from the inline position and because of
that guys could emerge as a consistent
top 10 fantasy tight end when we need
him the most
all right guys let's jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
State Farm where the personal price plan
is all about creating a price just for
you all the start sets you guys got them
send them my way we're gonna start off
with one from at kpat 12. one bench Dark
Horse player good question I actually
have a couple for you so first of all
Titans backup running back doncho
Hilliard is someone that we actually had
a start sick question earlier about him
but when you look at the stretch run
guys yes it's looking fantastic for
Derrick Henry as long as Derrick Henry
is out there currently leads the NFL and
Rush attempts and no I'm not a doctor
I'm not trying to predict injuries but
we see how quickly guys like Donovan
Knight and just whatever random running
back that we didn't even know of before
a couple weeks ago can all of a sudden
swing the fantasy season on its head and
I think that's what we could have at Don
Trail Hilliard God forbid something
happens to Derrick Henry so looking at
this Titans team over the next three
weeks guys Jaguars Chargers and Texans
I'm not sure if you could pick three
defenses that you'd rather have your
running back going up against than these
guys down the stretch so unlike Pollard
Madison I mean Pollard's not even a
handcuff anymore but you know unlike
these guys that we did draft in the top
10 rounds and that are probably going to
be owned in more leagues than not Don
Joe hurry continues to stick out as one
of the handcuffs of a top 10 back that
just isn't owned in too many leagues so
no I don't think the Titans would just
turn over the Derrick Henry rule to
doncho Hilliard last season when Henry
got hurt we did see a lot of Hassan
excuse me a lot of Deontay Foreman
alongside doncho Hilliard this year
those competition is just Joey Chestnut
and then also fourth down rookie Hassan
Haskins Julius Chestnut I'm sorry not
the hot dog guy the undrafted running
back Julius Chestnut so I really think
Don show Hillary would have a chance to
be a middle class man's Austin Eckler
basically if Derrick Henry got hurt and
that should mean a lot of fantasy points
and an offense likely ready to pass more
two other disguise real quick don't need
that big explanation but Matt breida the
New York Giants saquon Barkley already
having this neck issue similar sentiment
there where no we're not exactly
Crossing out saquon's name and subbing
in map Rita but still someone that would
be on the cover of you know every single
waiver wire article written the next
week
all right from at Jake Brown Pacheco
white Sanders or Pollard so if Leonard
fournette gets ruled out out then we
would go over shop white just for that
sweet pass game role but otherwise it's
going to be Tony Paula for me game
script is too great Cowboys number one
ranked scoring offense over the last
four weeks of action do not take paulard
out of that fantasy lineup if you can
all at all help it
from at Vic warnigeris Dobbins worth the
number one waiver ad uh you're in one of
those leagues without Fab I hate least
without Fab it just kind of ruins
everything for me but I would actually
say no the only problem with Dobbins in
this Baltimore Ravens backfield guys
like even if he takes over which I think
is skeptical with a healthy Gus Edwards
also there and Kenyan Drake and Justice
Hill staying involved Ravens running
backs this season are tied for last in
total targets and their bottom five in
Rush attempts and I don't think having
Tyler Huntley under Center is really
going to be changing that with how much
he runs so Dobbins hey maybe he can
crack you know the rb3 landscape down
the stretch but I don't think you would
you probably need to be blowing your
number one waiver wire ad on him
at JM melley is Cordero droppable got
Chubb etm Walker and knight uh yeah this
pains me I have been the longtime
president of the Cordero Patterson fan
club but it's Arthur Smith's world and
he just wants to continue featuring
Tyler algier who is fine I'm not trying
to hate on Tower algeer but man guys
it's like we're hoping that our third
round rookie QB and Desmond Ritter is
going to be the Savior for our guy
Cordero Patterson I do think he still
has a chance of fighting The End Zone
you know once or twice have missed his
10 to 15 touches per game but in terms
of you know those running backs you have
you would not be starting Patterson over
any of them if there is a great wide
receiver or tight end out there and you
need them okay it's fine I would try to
keep cpat though if possible I'm
guessing you are in a smaller League
though so it's not the most egregious
thing I've ever seen at the real GM uh
Kyron Williams Jalen Warren or Travis
Homer
this one's tough because you gotta make
the decision tonight I would probably
hold out and lean to Travis Homer it
doesn't look great for Kenneth Walker
although with Pete Carroll the ultimate
Optimist I'm not exactly sure that we
can get a great read on whatever he has
to say about injuries Jalen Warren I am
expecting nicotine to be the Fairly
clear-cut backup behind Naji Harris who
has at least been able to practice in a
limited fashion this week and at least
Travis Homer has the potential lead RB
for your Seattle Seahawks this weekend
so Karen Williams with Malcolm Brown
being active with Cam maker is a
candidate to just continue being the
lead back just not confident trusting
him enough in week 14.
from at vasgrosa James Cook or rashab Y
at the flex definitely rashab white no
matter what it was a good week to see
James Cook take that nice step and
actually lead the backfield but that's
set guys Devin Singletary and even 9
Hines were also very involved so with
James Cook and even someone like Donovan
Knight like it's very good no we're
talking about them because they were
absolute non-entities in the fantasy
world here as early as recently as a
couple of weeks ago but I just want to
get this through your heads though still
three back committees and not guys that
need to be started over someone like
Rashad white who should continue to see
you know really fantasy friendly targets
from Tom Brady love love love you guys
in the chat keep the questions coming we
got time for plenty more want to give a
quick shout out though to at Ryan Ribero
one Fantasy Star that could flop down to
stretch so I'm not saying he will flop
but what's going on with saquon Barkley
guys I mean it's one of those things
where he was so good in the first five
six weeks of the year we basically were
like oh how could anyone ever fade
saquon again saquon's back you know come
back player of the year or the Giants
going to be paying them a ton next
off-season when his contracts up him you
look up over the past month of action
and Sequon guys is starting to look a
little bit more like 2021 safe one which
is believe me not a good thing I mean it
was hard to even tell the difference
between saquon and Devonte Booker for
long stretches of last season so you
look at it and in his first six games of
the year we actually have Barkley
averaging 128.5 total yards in his last
six games just 87 and a half average
actually drops just 56 combined rushing
and receiving yards over his past three
games so honestly guys he just hasn't
been very good this season when he busts
the big plays everything is great but
when he doesn't we're looking at one of
the League's worst running backs in
terms of picking up yards after contact
I do think that stat can be skewed
sometimes you know a guy breaks attack
with a line of scrimmage runs for a
50-yard touchdown that's 50 yards after
contact but I went a little bit further
I looked at the percentage of carries
that guys have where they get at least
two yards or more after contact and only
James Robinson has been worse than
saquon at that in a sample of over 50
running backs and also guess what we're
talking about a bottom eight running
back in terms of yards for outrun and
PFF receiving grades so hey saquon he's
getting the workload you know he's one
of these fantasy guys that I call like
down with your ship type players like
Mark Andrews has been a little bit
disappointing too where the usage is
there the talents there seemingly at
least we've seen it in the past he
should be the future guy of the offense
you cannot bench saquon Barkley but I
would not be surprised if he continues
to disappoint down the stretch sadly
when we need him most
all right guys more start sets love them
keep them coming at T winners uh Brandon
ayuk or Corey Davis gonna still be ayuk
for me but Corey Davis is starting to
make it close it is going to be a
downgrade with Brock Purdy under Center
in San Francisco that said I don't see
you know the overall volume availability
being all that different for ayuk versus
Corey Davis and going up against that
Bill's team look the Mike White era has
been fun but we all just kind of refuse
to talk about when Mike White faces
Bill's defense last year and threw four
interceptions so yes it's good that we
have some counting stat highs he's
thrown for over 300 yards now and three
of his five career starts but don't get
too carried away with the Mike White you
know just era that we're now entering as
a country I guess uh that's a tough name
but Justin Herbert or Kirk Cousins yeah
it gotta be Justin Herbert man come on
what's the I mean I know Herbert wasn't
great last week but it's still Justin
Herbert here let's not get too carried
away from G-Men miles Sanders James Cook
or P Ryan for your Flex assuming Joe
Mixon is back which he is expecting to
play this week week I will be taking
miles Sanders from that group
again good game for James Cook last week
but guys at Miles Sanders credit to Nick
sariani the Eagles head coach for really
adjusting his game plan relative to what
the defense does bad novel concept I
know but when they face the Packers a
couple weeks ago pretty bad front seven
at least you know in their injury
riddled State Jalen hurts only threw the
ball 28 times last week they faced the
Titans who have shut down pretty much
everyone on the ground except sequence
and that was all the way back in week
one Jalen hurts had 39 pass attempts
even though they were up three scores
surely entered the second half Giants
ranked dead last in rushing yards before
contact per carries so Miles Sanders
don't be surprised if he makes these 15
to 20 Rush attempts he usually gets
going extra long way against the Giants
from Bobo Judy thielen or Burks in full
PPR I don't think Berks is going to play
this week with the concussion I would
take Jerry Judy assuming Cortland Sutton
is going to be sidelined from DAV who
day who day my friend who do I start Mac
Hollins or samaje piran it's going to be
Mac Hollins again if ah crap I guess you
don't know because Thursday night I
would still go with Mac Hollins
unfortunately with piran look we saw how
good of a handcuff he can be but I just
don't think that we're gonna see them do
anything outrageous in terms of taking
away Joe mixon's job or anything like
that so still give me mac Hollins really
that has a chance to be the number two
pass game option in Las Vegas during any
given week also we got a dab in Santa in
the fold gotta be loving that snow
Santa's Davin it's a great day to be
great here on BR Fantasy Live uh from
app uh Pat dilemmo my bad Mike Evans or
Deontay Foreman at the flex I know it's
been so rough for Mike Evans guys that
said Deonte Foreman dealing with the
calf injury he might not be able to make
it it out there and it's a situation
with Deontay Foreman where when the
Panthers are able to get a lead and play
ahead then okay Deontay Foreman has a
chance to rack up these 20 plus touches
but the floor there has been brutal to
be Hubbard before the buy was starting
to eat more into the workload I think
Deontay Foreman is a pretty touchdown
dependent rb2 rb3 type and a panther's
offense that I don't expect to be
scoring touchdowns more weeks than not
give me Mike Evans
from Green Bean Kyron Williams or Jeff
Wilson gonna be Jeff Wilson for me again
I know it's rough with with Kyron trying
to figure out this Ram's backfield and I
know Jeff Wilson's usage last week was
terrible that said Raheem moster only
had seven Rush attempts in his own right
I do think it'll be 50 50 hot hand more
so than we thought it's going to be the
rest of the way but still should be some
scoring opportunities for Jeff Wilson in
a dolphins offense that we're still
expecting to see plenty of goodness from
second highest implied team total of the
week behind only the Cowboys from
Anthony Hall etn Zeke or Swift in full
PPR oh this is a tough one I have etn
just barely ahead of Swift at this point
and Zeke's a great player too you better
have a really good lineup over there man
to have any of these guys sitting on
your bench but you're impressed me with
it and for that I will take etn he has
the biggest role of these three running
backs yes DeAndre Swift is back in the
good graces he led the team and snaps
and touches last week still have three
guys involved though Jamal Williams and
Justin Jackson are not going away right
obviously Zeke is splitting things up
with Tony Pollard etn he's playing over
80 percent of the offensive snaps every
week out there expect better days ahead
for him and his Jaguars offense
from s Connors Jamal Williams or Deontay
Foreman give me Jamal Williams very
similar roles and I think the Lions
scoring offense has a lot higher upside
than the Panthers hot take there I know
or Rodriguez Darius Slayton or George
Pickens at the flex if Deontay Johnson
ends up getting hurt I mean he is hurt
right now with the hip injury if he
doesn't play then give me George Pickens
otherwise I do think Dairy slate would
be the better choice and I'm just going
to rip off a few here before we get out
of here guys Jonathan Fidalgo Slayton
Cooper or DJ Moore I am going with the
Mari Cooper trusting DeSean Watson to
improve a little bit Chester chalupa
Metcalf or DeAndre Hopkins this week
oh that's tough if there is any amount
of doubt about Hopkins availability on
Monday night just go at Metcalf as long
as we're good though I would still lean
towards DeAndre Hopkins
nasty relis Conklin or najoku Dave and
the joku with Watson already been
practicing a limited fashion both days
this week feeling better about najoku
here moving forward I think honestly
guys if he stays healthy top six tight
end the rest of the way to origino give
me Tua calm cool Damon Harris from
Michael Carter I don't think Damon
Harris is going to play and you'd have
to wait until Monday so give me Michael
Carter uh dollar Pierce or Swift
definitely DeAndre Swift and Bob enter
etn or white if Leonard fournette does
not play then I would take Rashad white
if he does play then give me Travis etn
and with that guy it's going to wrap up
our last BR Fantasy Live of the Season
again can't thank you all enough for
tuning in if you guys have enjoyed
hearing me talk about fantasy you can
hear me almost every day of the week on
the PFF fantasy football podcast and
over on Twitter at iheartit so again
thank you for all the questions thank
you for just Good Vibes and we've had a
lot of fun here over these last 14 plus
weeks of action and finally best of luck
go get those playoff spots and go win
and the thing it's always a great day to
be great so thank you guys again for
tuning in the BR Fantasy Live this
season I'm Ian Hardison until next time
take care everybody